[Music]
is the best
game leader in the world in terms of
bringing new talent together and
actually making them win stuff
it seems crazy how this guy over and
over again throughout his career has
been able to get star players playing to
the best of their ability
because he's coming in not just ask the
canadian game leader pretty much
remaking the whole team if they're going
to be successful
everybody felt like it was their major
but it wasn't meant to be
not today it is over
zip knicks down to five hp and it's not
going to be enough 16-7 when faze have
done it they
are your e-league champions
he was told you can pick whoever you
want to play with you could build up
this team and we want to have a tier one
team and what does he do
at the end of the year he wants the
biggest tournament kerrigan once again
brings everyone together and he makes
them perform
what you've built up you really want to
keep that legacy
finn kerrigan anderson was born to a
german mother and danish father in 1990
and like many pro players his older
brother introduced him to cs
when i played country when i was younger
it it made me excited
i pushed myself to become better the i
think it was the
the thing of of competing against other
people in a video game that everybody
plays
to become better so it has to be the
competitiveness
that really took my drive typical for
finn is
that he is very determined
[Music]
and once i had my first tournament even
before that i beat my brother he came in
smashed me on down and said
stop joining my public server and then
he stopped and i have to find somewhere
else to beat
the cs of kerrigan's youth was 1.6 and
he came up through the ranks playing
against some of the game's best
before arguably reaching his peak toward
the end of the game's lifespan
his fame even spilled over into the real
world yeah i was actually back in high
school that some people came over and i
was
you know when you go to high school you
get new friends and you want to try to
to be a normal person that that
escalated pretty quickly
so i just have to tell my close friends
that
that might be sometimes i can't go out
party because of
what i love to do is competing in in a
video game so
it's understandable that a 21 year old
kerrigan had big expectations for his cs
go career but those early years were
difficult when it's a new
new game you try to get all players in
and you and you just feel like they're
only playing for the money
they're not really motivated to get to
the best so i did everything in those
two years
on to the end i found myself that i
don't really think that somebody could
call the way i would like to play in a
team
after bouncing around for a couple of
years kerrigan finally got his shot
with team solomid's entry into
counter-strike kerrigan had tried a
limited in-game leader role on previous
teams so since i became pro when i was
15 16 years old i was
sometimes engineering some teams in 1.6
so
i've always been interested in tactical
approach but the dignitas tsm roster
would be his first chance to fully
implement
his system the way he wanted on to the
end i found myself that
i don't really think that somebody could
call the way i would like to play in the
team
so when the offer finally came back
could be
really in the middle for tsm instead of
took it and
actually gave the last chance i thought
that team would be my last team
already 24 with two years of mixed
results behind him it's understandable
why he might expect an early exit from
the sport
and retaking this is going to be down
near impossible molotov as well making
sure he only has one entrance but he's
going to be charging through and he goes
down
sush with the kill and now he's survived
copenhagen wolves
1917 they make it to the playoffs but
there was another reason as well
unlike so many esports professionals
kerrigan hadn't bet everything on the
game
he had been completing a dual masters in
business administration and accounting
a way to ensure that there was a life
waiting after counter-strike
so there was a decision made by me right
before i joined tsm
what's now astralis today that i
actually wanted to stop
and and then get on get along with my
new career
in in my master degree so there was a
time
there i was thinking about what to do i
gave it a chance for six months
at that point when i finished my degree
i gave my paper to my father said
now you try to tell me take your nurse
to degree every year
here you got it now i'm going proceed
the roster that he joined was composed
entirely of danish players
and the style that developed was
kerrigan's tactical
but aggressive informed by his
opponent's tendencies but also by
kerrigan's instincts in the heat of the
moment
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
yes
we can start out really fast pace but we
have all these executes where it's all
about getting in their face and
and that's the way i mess as a player so
if i'm feeling the game these explosive
things where create a lot more space for
my players and let them play the like
mid-rounds getting into a side and then
in theory we played these three and
threes right he also became known for
his unpredictability in the map veto
where he was willing to play maps his
team didn't prefer as long as it made
things worse for his opponents
but i like to throw in a curveball here
and there
because i know people prepare a lot that
means you can't prepare seven maps per
team
so you prepare three or four which most
likely gonna happen right
that means if you can get the fifth map
that didn't expect then you have a good
situation in my opinion
tsm's coming out party was at the face
at league 2015 stage one finals
where as europe's fifth seed they
defeated nadas vincere twice in the
group stage
then they went on to tuo fanatic yeah
that fanatic there's a fragrance
occasionally b he's got four he needs to
find it free but he will not get air in
time
but does he have time to defuse a bomb
yeah he does and that is gg
2-0 to tsm taking down fnatic
crashing out of the tournament tsm make
it
to the final and despite getting
absolutely blown out in map one
tsm took the finals from nip two to one
and all the nays come in
and it's not looking too bad at the
moment for either team but three on two
now as kerrigan claims one over the top
with the five seven and
hurricane finishes off you hear them
just elated
amazing stuff tsm will be
our winners here they'll be crowned
champions that face it stage one
land finals live from london england and
they deserved it
the summer of 2015 was this roster's
glory days as they were consistently in
the discussion at the game's biggest
tournaments
but kerrigan achieved more than just
counter-strike glory he also finished
his duel masters at the same time he was
playing professional counter-strike on
one of the world's best teams
january and december i really never had
christmas i was
studying reading up and all the stuff
that i missed out on
and then when general exchange was done
i played for six months again
did the same thing in the summer and so
sort of that's the way i did it
i'm lucky in denmark you don't have to
be meet up in person
university so i can stay home and study
myself so
in 2016 the team left tsm then briefly
became team question mark before
announcing the creation of astralis
the first player-owned organization in
cs go
but even as astralis blazed a new path
kerrigan's future with the team was put
in jeopardy when they started losing to
opponents that on paper
they should have handled easily but i
just think we haven't delivered as a
team
as a unit as a whole team there's
something
going on within the team and it's
definitely confidence or it's the
confidence our map pool confidence our
playing style
as time went on the team's confidence in
kerrigan's leadership style faltered
and the system broke down and they
picked up a molotov oh pith that's so
big
when he puts it lower he actually puts
it lower which means device still has a
chance at this
i'm not sure why he's right towards the
low around but here we go then it's
gonna be device coming into the face
that fuse comes in
needs to go it's a kid he doesn't even
face it oh
device misreads it all together nlp
finding that very easy to finish that
one off they actually hit siri's point
now
despite the team's dazzling performances
in the summer of 2015
they couldn't recapture the magic and
kerrigan was benched
[Music]
but the kerrigan of 2014 who wondered
whether he'd keep playing and was
leaning towards a career in his academic
field
was gone in his place was someone who
wanted to see his leadership style
fully realized and there was a team
willing to give him another chance
when you talk about the face face came
with an incredible good offer
saying you can build your own team here
there is
only one player we want to be in the lab
in the future and that is rain
so we want to build this team around you
and reign and i told them that that
i hope that they live up to the
expectation of building a team together
over a period of time
kerrigan's entrance to faze then ranked
15th was noticeable
they immediately improved but bigger
things
were still to come yeah i think we
always at some point knew we're gonna
get nico
like that was the whole goal of this
team that becoming that good that nico
would actually change the lineup
because he needed that one big superstar
that could
bring us home some trophies we can build
around
many players but you always need one you
can rely on and unlike his previous all
danish squad
this was a roster from all across europe
with the young superstar alongside
kerrigan
the future looked bright and so did the
tournament results
over the course of several months in
2017 the team reached the finals of four
tournaments
including a win at starladder i-league
star series season three over astralis
nico the addition kerrigan the in-game
leader they finally look more team what
a shot though from zinfix
he'll go on to the ak device needs to be
extremely good on the way through knows
what's in the corner hits it
incredible but no way it's done they
take down devices civics is found in
phase clan
with all the tools will extinguish
the chances of astralis to repeat kirin
is gonna love it nikko's gonna lead the
way it's phase that win in starladder
[Applause]
this is actually a trend for kerrigan
even later after his time with faze he
has constantly performed well against
those he has led in the past
every time we play our old teammates
from other clans
if you uh win against them you have to
pay queen bbq
so we were probably going to go here
eight times this week
to be honest i throw out my stratbook
when i play old teams
all these small adjustments i do is
basically off
in feeling and especially when i play my
teammates i'm just this 10 percent moan
because i want to prove
to myself and everybody else that it was
a mistake and i the way i want to call
also works
and step by step they are on the verge
of the finals here
the face of this one kill from nico and
there it is
it's phased to the un sydney finals
but faze wasn't done adding pieces and
kerrigan would soon be teammates with
yet more
superstars the addition of olofmeister
and guardian gave faze more firepower
than any team in
history but on a roster filled with
stars who would be willing to take a
back seat
and could a super team like this even
work the team's highly anticipated first
outing was
not encouraging olaf breaking out and
now they're gonna try and go for it mo
shots him down in 1613 gambit survive
face all nuke and win it that's so
impressive and they attacked the one
weakness that faze really really kind of
had in this series was
a little bit of that inexperience of
playing together of understanding
how they were going to rotate across the
map the different positions they'd be in
they didn't make it past the group stage
at dreamhack masters malmo 2017
but rather than simply shake it off
kerrigan and the team went to work
trying to figure out how best to operate
with their newest members
yeah so before the tournament started we
didn't have that much practice
and i think one of the mistakes i did as
in game leader was believing that the
new lineup would fit into the map
we had um i it was a momentous situation
where we realized
how where's our map practices practice
but an official game is always different
and
that's the that's the way it is
sometimes with a new lineup after malmo
faze finally hit their stride under
kerrigan's leadership winning a number
of high-profile events
including another win against astralis
at the e-league cs go premiere but can
you
hold on to this bomb sign alone that is
information though now faze are gonna
pounce they know that they can push on
to this site that there were two players
there for straws the flash is in it's
good olefmeister takes down dupreeh
now they know where the remaining
players are coming from and it is
inevitable it is
over zip knicks down to five hp and it's
not gonna be enough
16-7 win faze have done it they are your
e-league champions
kerrigan leads us to i mean he leads his
team of super stars
to dethrone the kings a big investment
in this but it was obviously worth it
here they are faze ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
for the next three months kerrigan's
version of faze were among the favorites
at
every event they attended but at 2018's
e-league boston major
the unthinkable happened
can he do it again he's in this position
before to win phase
around a very important very crucial one
can he deny cloud9
from this position before he cannot miss
a single shot guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
always happens
they made it work clown nine
are your elite major champions
[Music]
everybody felt like it was their major
but it wasn't meant to be
while the team didn't immediately drop
off they were heavily impacted by
olofmeister's on and off departure over
three months starting in april
it wasn't all poor finishes but faze had
slipped far from their previous heights
by december kerrigan was benched and at
this point
it wouldn't have been surprising to see
a graceful retirement
but kerrigan wasn't planning on one um
so obviously
i saved all the motivation after like
okay whenever i get a team i'm
gonna show the world i'm not done the 28
year old spent some time on loan to envy
before being transferred back to a team
he knew
all too well mousesports again it was a
multinational roster but unlike phase
where they had to pursue nico
this team already had an obvious
superstar in rocks
yeah that smoke might actually help them
with the rocks and the great corners
in and he gets headshots two young guns
with potential in walks
and frozen it's fine again it's greek
versus precise as always
it was six
the timings started to swing towards
vitality frozen doing what he can five
seconds to go
he's gonna get the bomb down it's gonna
get the bomb oh what they've got
what the hell is that from frozen that
doesn't make any sense
and a six-year mouse veteran named chris
j try and hold off the rotations oscar's
gone chris isn't up still in the picture
i'm still very much in the realm oh
chris he's found three it's down to a
two on two
chris can he close this with an x oh my
god
it didn't take that long for the
kerrigan effect to manifest once more
it was obvious that this was a team that
could do damage
they were ranked as high as number two
in the world early in 2020
and kerrigan's style shone through once
again with huge wins at the esl pro
league season 10 finals and csm at five
and five consecutive finals appearances
from november 2019 to early into the
next year
the team looked like they could contend
for a major and the major
really is the question if this roster
were to win both christie and kerrigan
would be the oldest major winners to
date
while a major would be a fitting
capstone to kerrigan's career
it's fair to say that he has made an
incredible mark on cs
even without it because whether he was
fragging out in 1.6
or leading an unlikely group to victory
step by step in the right direction
raised
completely unfazed look at this nico
finds dupree
and step by step they are on the verge
of getting to the finals here
the face landed this one kill from ligo
and there it is
to the audience kerrigan always made us
believe that the best rosters need more
than just firepower to succeed
they need leadership they need an
architect
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages